my first year at the Gates Foundation
has been terrific I feel like every day
is a gift I have enormous respect and
pride in my colleagues and every day I
meet somebody who amazes me I think my
self-awareness as a leader comes from
the energy i get from colleagues one of
my favorite things to do is to ask for
feedback or to learn from colleagues and
the self-awareness i have is is really
comes from a place of deep respect for
what other people know and contribute as
a leader in 2015 I've grown to be fond
of social media and so I'm one of those
people who was on Twitter and on
Facebook and and I think that the social
network has enormous power to bring
people together and to connect people in
meaningful ways as a physician so often
an impediment to getting things done is
human behavior we're trying to change
human behavior all the time stop smoking
exercise more get your children
vaccinated human behavior is a powerful
positive and some human behaviors can be
a powerful negative in really advancing
health worldwide and accomplishing the
things that we're trying to accomplish
here so I'm intrigued by the power of
connecting people of some of the facts
that are well known in medicine about if
your neighborhoods healthy you tend to
be healthy if your social circle whether
it's real or virtual is unhealthy and
has unhealthy habits so do you so I
think in in the causes we care about and
advancing both education in the US and
global health and global development
worldwide I feel like we've only
scratched the surface of how we use
human connection whatever technology
allows for that human connection in
meaningful ways to help us with what
we're trying to do I think I've enjoyed
my first year here especially because we
have so many talented passionate people
who I learn from every day
you